a lot of people I saw had a theory
regarding the idea of calm etc etc so I
can I can confirm that I have a new
single coming out tonight at midnight
it's called you need to calm down I'm so
excited for you to hear it it's out at
midnight Eastern everywhere and the
video doesn't come out for another
couple days because I wanted you to hear
the song first and then see the video
because the video is very worth the wait
there's a lot going on in the video and
so I wanted that to be like a separate a
separate discovery but the video will be
out Monday June 17 Taylor Swift making
all sorts of announcements on her
Instagram live yes her new single you
need to calm down we'll be out tonight
and that title should sound familiar
element Paul so to play but that's not
all
so another thing that you were
absolutely correct about was the album
title um the album is called lover it's
coming out August 23rd and yes the date
has a special significance and an easy
way to remember that date is that August
is the eighth month of the year and then
23 to +3 so you just add it all together
eight plus two plus three equals I'm
obnoxious so you know everything you
know if you just want to remember that
by like I would adds up to 13 there's an
easy easy way to do it today previously
said the name was in the me video once
and said twice which is true
[Music]
and the title of the 18 track album
makes sense this album in tone it's very
romantic
and not just not just simply
thematically like like it's all love
songs or something because I think that
the idea of something being romantic it
doesn't have to be a happy song or I
think that romance can be you can find
romance and loneliness or sadness or
going through a conflict or dealing with
things in your life I think that it just
kind of looks at those things with a
very romantic gaze the cover was shot by
an amazing amazing photographer named
Valerio Rocha check her out tell her how
great she is because she shot this cover
and it's this and there you have it fans
went nuts over the news including
Lindsay Lohan who was commenting on the
stream and all we can say is we can't
wait for Taylor's new tunes
[Music]